Let's take a look at this method signature.
We can see that ajax takes in URL and settings.
And, settings come within these square brackets.
In general, square brackets within documentation means that
something is optional.
So, if we look at settings, we see that, in fact, all settings are optional.
So, in all reality all you really need is a URL for an AJAX request.
AJAX has another signature where your just passing in settings, and
settings are optional.
This leads to an interesting situation, let's talk about this for a second.
The correct answer to this questions going to be URL, but
we can see that with this function signature we don't even need settings,
settings are in fact optional.
And, there is no url.
so, you actually can call an ajax request without passing in anything to it.
But, that would be kind of pointless,
because while it would succeed, it wouldn't go anywhere.
So, you're not really doing much of a request.
In terms of real world requests, most post requests will probably have a url and
some data with them.
Because in a post request, you're usually sending off data.
And, GET request, in the real world, generally have a url along with some type
of call back function and some optional data passed along with the GET request.
But, the only thing that's really necessary to send off a functional AJAX
request is a url string